there are reports out there that the
governor was not listening to science he
was listening to hospital
lobbyists who were saying to him right
we can't take these
patients for very long you know they're
not maybe paying
customers we need to get them over to
some place else so that we can allow for
more people to come in
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the senior meteorologist at fox news
author of the new book make your own
sunshine inspiring stories of people who
find light in dark times
and a woman who is not a big fan of new
york governor
andrew cuomo janice dean finally
welcome to the reuben report oh my gosh
thank you for having me my friend
how'd you like that little addition that
i gave to your bio there did that does
that feel right to you
you know i gotta tell you if you told me
a year ago that i would be in the middle
of a
storm involving the governor of new york
i would have said what are you drinking
and where can i get some well you
you certainly are and you know my
audience knows i try to do these
interviews
really as free form as possible but i
thought with this
interview i'm going to do it a little
more intentionally because the book
which i've been reading over the last
couple of days it's it's so light and
warm
and decent and it puts a smile on your
face
but this last year you really have
stepped into a fight that
that so many of us are dealing with at
so many different levels
so for people that have no idea about
what
has gone on in your life in the past
year can you just lay it out
how did this all start and when did you
decide to really get
into the public fight march
25th was the order which governor cuomo
put his signature on that allowed
coveted positive patients into nursing
homes
9 000 of them and that was a fairly
recent development
the reason why i'm so interested in this
topic is because we lost my
husband's parents in separate elder care
facilities
in late march we lost his dad and in
april about two weeks later we lost his
mother
and obviously tragic i never planned to
be someone who
is a spokesperson on behalf of uh
you know my husband's parents and
thousands of others that we lost
but i felt like i had to because when i
saw the governor on television programs
like his brothers on cnn
joking around and not even approaching
the nursing home issue
that's when i decided to get a little
bit angry because
i felt like my husband's parents in the
situation that they were presented with
unknowingly was not being represented
fairly
in the mainstream media and you know
going back to his parents we didn't even
know
there was a march 25th order and the
plan was we were supposed to have both
of them in an
uh an assisted living residence close to
us on long island
i feel um you know a kindred spirits
with people who have to talk about
what to do with their aging parents
their health was failing them
they lived in a four-story walk-up in
brooklyn for 50 years we had many
conversations about getting them out of
there because they were going to have
issues trying to go up and down the
stairs so for many years the
conversation was there we wanted to get
them into a different place
we offered to help them monetarily and
they
just never wanted to take that they just
said we're just going to stick it out we
love it here
and we'll deal with it as it comes and
as it happened his dad got dementia his
health was failing him
his mom was very spry for you know a 75
76 year old but she had back problems
she had problems walking
and so it got to the point where we had
aids going to visit them
that wasn't working out so we took his
mom
to look at assisted facilities uh
and she loved the one close to us on
long island she
signed the paperwork his father was in
bad health so we had to get him in
better shape before he could he could
join her in the assisted living
residence
um and that's when cobot happened i mean
we hadn't even cleared out their
apartment
the we were still paying the rent for
them so it was very recent
that we had put them in the in the elder
care facilities they had never been
separated in their lives
and we were just hoping to get mickey
his father in better shape so
cobit happened we were in quarantine in
early march
we weren't able to see them we were
getting updates um
from their separate elder care
facilities sean was able to talk to his
mom
every day um because she was you know
she was
lucid his dad obviously was tough
because he had dementia
we got a call on a saturday morning in
late march
not even knowing he was ill and they
said that
mickey was not feeling well he was
running a fever
and so of course we were concerned and
we were talking about what we were going
to do and three hours later
we get a call saying he was dead
we had no idea he had died of covid
until we saw the death certificate and
sean had to deliver the news to his
mother
um and to say that she was heartbroken
is an understatement she got
sick in her assisted living facility was
diagnosed with covid when they brought
her to the hospital and she died in the
hospital
several days later the last thing she
asked my husband
to do was put her name on the easter
gifts for the kids
[Music]
so i never wanted to tell their story my
husband is a very private person
he's not on tv he's not a broadcaster
he's a
firefighter 25 years in the department
his dad was a firefighter as well
but when i wasn't seeing the coverage
of the nursing home issue and the fact
that i was finding out that cuomo wasn't
counting those that died in the hospital
like my mother-in-law
that's when i decided it was time to
tell my story our story
so that at least somebody anybody
would you know find out that this was
actually something that was happening in
new york
yeah boy all right there's there's so
many sort of offshoots where we go there
first off i have to say i don't if you
know this but i'm actually from long
island as well and i know a lot of long
island firefighters so i have no doubt
that sean is a great guy because every
single one of them that i know
are are great people um well i guess
first just for a little more on
on the timeline so how how long was it
that your folks didn't see each other or
your
your in-laws didn't see each other
before you got that call
about your father-in-law well you know
it started
out that both mickey and dee were in the
nursing home together
uh but his mother was in better shape so
that's when she went to the assisted
living residence and i would say they
were probably apart for
a few weeks um so they were
you know they were apart for a few weeks
but they they knew that they would be
together at some point at the assisted
living residence
um so you know it it wasn't very long
uh that cove had happened um when they
were you know
when they were in this situation do you
remember
when cuomo signed that piece of
legislation or whatever it was do you
remember thinking
uh oh this could be a problem there were
so many things happening at once it was
almost like impossible to make sense of
any of it back then i know it's hard to
remember
just a year ago we didn't know about it
dave
i mean honestly i found out about it
after they had died
no one told us about it you know i
remember the red flag
after the fact was that we got a call
about mickey
uh i would say about a week before he
passed away
saying that they were going to move to
him to another floor because they were
going to allow for more
people to come into the residence but
they didn't say infected patients
and we had no idea we only learned
after they had died that there was a
mandate in place to put covet positive
patients
so you know that's a big deal i think
whose responsibility would that have
been
the nursing home the assisted living
residents someone should have told us
but the other point of that is that we
weren't able to see
them you know we were in quarantine sean
did see his mom
before she got sick he dropped off
flowers
and a card after his dad had passed away
and he was able to see her six
feet away with a mask on but he wasn't
able to go and hug her
you know so there were all these things
in place where we physically
couldn't do anything we were all you
know you were you're almost
jailed you know you couldn't move you
couldn't find things out you couldn't go
see them you couldn't bring them to you
you know obviously if i had known about
a march 25th order we would have done
things very differently we would have
found a way to bring them here
you know his sister-in-law would have
taken one of them we would have done
something
yeah look we all know hindsight is 20
20. but do you think in retrospect that
the nursing homes themselves
should have done different things should
have just protested the order
i mean do you think that they some of
them may have sort of known i know that
we have more info now so i know it's
tough to to do that kind of
quarterbacking
from what i know and the people that
i've talked with
that work in nursing homes they did not
want to take the covet positive patients
they felt they had no
choice and if you read the order they
weren't allowed to even
test them they were prohibited from
testing them for covid
so you know you know that in itself
is is like if you couldn't test them
then you didn't know if they even had
the virus
so what what could be the logic behind
not
being allowed to test people that you're
bringing into the home
well this is a bigger broader subject
that i think we need to investigate
there are
several investigations into the nursing
home issue which i am grateful for
there's a federal one and there's an fbi
one
and what i want to know is first of all
the origins of the march 25th order
where did that come from because it's
not based on science we all knew that
putting
infected patients into where our most
vulnerable live
is not scientific it was going to spread
like wildfire which is what our governor
said as well
that it would be like wildfire through
dry
grass so i want to know where that order
came from there are reports out there
that the governor was not listening to
science he was listening to
hospital lobbyists who were saying to
him right
we can't take these patients for very
long you know they're not maybe
paying customers we need to get them
over to some place
else so that we can allow for more
people to come in at the beginning of
the pandemic
he had no idea we thought there was
going to be thousands upon thousands of
people that were going to
come into the hospitals and take over
the beds so i at the beginning i don't
blame him for not really knowing what to
do
and sort of saying well maybe we should
put them the back end but
it was in place for 46 days and
then it was reversed and scrubbed from
the website
so that should also tell you something i
think there is
corruption involved i think there is a
criminal aspect to it i think it
involves hospital lobbyists
and the curious thing as well is that
cuomo
put it in place for a blanket immunity
for
all of the nursing homes so that we
could not sue them
just a couple of days after that march
25th order wasn't was put into effect
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell